and finally new rule Democrats have to
give me a reason to live as I mentioned
last week in this space the Muller
report that was our shot with the
dysfunctional Congress and a traitorous
Attorney General it fell to one man to
stop the madness and when he didn't I
got to tell you it broke me a little bit
I am for the first time in my life using
marijuana for legitimate medical reason
yesterday I wandered into a dispensary
and said give me the strongest strain of
indigo you have and the guy said sir
this is a baskin-robbins
[Applause]
I admit it I've let myself go why not
what's the point Trump gets away with
everything
he beat the rap on Russia he's gotten
away with collusion and obstruction and
stealing Obama's Supreme Court seat so
many things were supposed to bring him
down charlotte's filled stormy Daniels
kids and cages Muller nothing does he
picked up Senate seats in the midterms
he got Kavanagh and Kanye he got the
entire Republican Party behind him
despite all the laws of economics the
stock market is up despite the laws of
nutrition he's alive
and despite the laws of laws he's not in
jail he was right about one thing
I am tired of him winning my current
position on politics is fetal I hear
people say just turn off the news I
can't it's my job and I'm not gonna
abandon my post
but I'm here to tell you that I think
I've found something that helps and I
need to tell you about it tonight
because it affects our relationship and
what it is is I bill Mahr and 100% all
in on and completely into ASMR that's
right
ASMR which stands for Oh autonomous
sensory meridian response and no it's
not that thing where you jerk off with a
belt around your neck that's it's an
internet phenomenon where people soothe
themselves by watching people whisper
and quietly touch and rub things
ASMR has become so popular it was even
in a Superbowl ad this year it's all
experienced something I know you're
thinking bill did you hit your head you
are the last guy we'd expect to be into
some crazy social media fad I know but
when all day long I have to see this
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
if I have to look at that in the day I
find it very helpful at night to watch
this
[Applause]
isn't it easier to accept that our
country is falling apart after you see
that guy so starting right now and
perhaps for a little while I will be
needing to do the show like this I know
it's a little weird but it's what I need
to do to be able to keep talking about
don't drop this paper
I'm sorry I can't go I've tried
everything
hot yoga scream therapy Adele scissor
this is what works for pain
[Laughter]
you do I'm telling you people this [ __ ]
really works when you're dealing with
the guy like Trump OS lied thousand
[Applause]
and he won't release his taxes even
though the law says he shall
[Applause]
and he brags about grabbing women by the
[ __ ] because he's a celebrity
[Applause]
they say fascism can't happen here I say
it already has
I say have Trump to cover a country that
wasn't America we would bomb it so don't
be ashamed of ASMR whatever you have to
do Dick Harry Potter wand rake it across
a Barry gobo record stir wet stir wet
Robin with a dildo
rub your penis against Donald row
[Applause]
do
[Applause]
whatever it takes because it worked
[Applause]
I hope I don't have to do that too much
I thank you for indulging me and
hopefully I'll be back to normal soon
until then to all of president Trump's
Russo Republican enablers who heard me
say a few minutes ago that I was broken
a little bit dream on traitors that's
not going to happen
[Applause]
you